here's another challenge for you
implements an array of nicknames for
your cat and use a control flow
structure to display them all control
flow structures and knock out our ways
of doing things programmatically in your
view they're similar to if statements
and loops but in your bindings in the
HTML for example what if you could have
a bunch of nicknames and you want to put
each one in its own div in my example
here I've put all of my nicknames in
their own li element now if you wanted
to do that you could use the for each
binding to render each one of them in
that particular way now also as with
anything new the phrases that knockout
uses can be intimidating control flow
sounds a little bit scary it's just a
fancy word for things that are nonlinear
like loops and conditionals like if
statements now this time I'm going to
ask you to figure out how to actually
implement this open up the knockout
documentation and click on that page
right there
read the page that talks about the for
each binding and have at it now actually
before you have at it remember to commit
your code in a repository at each step
so you can always reset if you code
yourself into a corner and if you do get
stuck or for example aren't sure how to
get the actual array item into the
bindings read the documentation more
thoroughly all the answers you need
should be there waiting for you